CYNTHIA THOMAS: Welcome to
NET 101, hybrid networking
for millions of users with
GCP and Twitter engineering.
My name is Cynthia Thomas,
I'm a networking specialist
at the Google Cloud.
And I'm accompanied by Todd.
TODD SIEGEL: Hi,
I'm Todd Siegel.
I'm a software engineer at
Twitter working on traffic
and our edge infrastructure.
CYNTHIA THOMAS:
Today we're going
to talk to you about how
Twitter manages traffic
to handle millions of tweets,
and leverages Google networking
to augment that capacity.
Let's get into it.
Twitter is leveraging
Google Cloud products
that are built on Google's
proven infrastructure.
You're probably able to
recognize some of these logos
here.
You supported over a billion
users on nine products,
all relying on Google
networking infrastructure.
We've learned a lot
and innovated a lot
to be able to
achieve such scale,
while ensuring reliability,
speed, and security.
That means better
reliability and performance
than the public internet
and other cloud providers.
Through this
experience, we've been
able to develop protocols
that improve networking
performance like BBR and QUIC.
BBR improves the previous
TCP congestion algorithm,
which was based on packet loss.
Instead, Google has
designed an algorithm
to respond to actual congestion
for available bandwidth
and minimal roundtrip times
for huge performance gains.
Another example of Google
networking innovation is QUIC.
Based on UDP, a transport layer
protocol that reduces latency
by eliminating the
number of handshakes
compared to HTTPS over TCP.
Twitter and Google
Cloud users already
benefit from these
higher throughput
lower latency gains by
accessing Google managed
services like Bigtable
and Cloud storage.
By the current numbers
we have 24 Cloud regions
across the globe and several
more are coming down the pike.
As you can see, Google's
made large investment
in infrastructure globally,
including undersea cables,
Cloud regions,
partnerships of ISPs
is to deploy, POPs
and CDNs of the edge.
We continue to grow our
data center and Cloud region
count each year.
This benefit means we can
rely on Google engineering
to deploy lively and
securely across the globe.
It's benefit, for
example, a Twitter user
anywhere in the world for
a better user experience.
Here we can see Google's
made a sizable investment
in physical
infrastructure globally.
Google has built
its own backbone
providing private connectivity
between Google Cloud regions,
data centers, and such.
Just as Twitter has leverage
Google infrastructure
for cloud services like Cloud
Bigtable, edge networking,
Cloud storage,
Google Cloud users
can also benefit from Google's
dedicated infrastructure
for performance and security.
As Todd will discuss,
Twitter has complemented
its own infrastructure
by bursting and adding
capacity using Google's
global footprints.
Twitter is already taking
advantage of Google edge
networking including our
POPs, for private dedicated
interconnects peering at or
Google finance for caching,
load balancing, and securing
against DDOS at the edge.
One major differentiator
for Google Cloud networking
is the Shared Global VPC model.
So Twitter takes advantage
of this model where the share
VPC allows centralized
management of Google Cloud
networking.
So that means subnets
and routes are
reachable across the
entire global of VPC, which
means great ease of
management while never
traversing the public internet.
Additionally this
means you can deploy
Google global constructs
like the Google Global Load
Balancers to deploy
at any cost VIPs,
minimizing the amount
of configuration,
and providing a great
end user experience.
So there is a host of Google
Cloud networking products
and capabilities that Google
Cloud provides powered
by our proven infrastructure.
We have various ways
to connect your on-prem
to our cloud, security workloads
with numerous security options,
and scale applications through
our load balancers and Cloud
CDN.
And furthermore take advantage
of orchestrate and workloads
through open source
standard platforms
like Kubernetes and
Istio, the roots
of which come from Google.
So during this
talk, we'll discuss
some of the edge networking
features that Twitter
leverages from Google to scale.
This includes the Google global
load balancer, and Cloud CDN.
Next, Todd will get into how
Twitter deploys at the edge.
TODD SIEGEL: Thanks, Cynthia.
So I'm going to talk a little
bit about Twitter's edge
network before we expanded
our network with Google,
and some of the issues
that we were facing
and how we solved them.
So Twitter's global
edge network is
made of multiple
points of presence
deployed throughout the world.
And we also have a
global backbone network
that this edge connects to.
The edge then forums traffic
on to our serving regions
that are located in a
few different places
throughout the world.
When we originally
deployed this network
we had different IP addresses
in different locations, Unicast
IPs or regional IPs,
and then we would
have different DNS responses
based on what the user was.
We eventually change
this to be globally
any cast VIPs, which greatly
improved availability
because of some of the issues
with DNS caching or imprecise
geolocation.
So availability was
good at this point,
however performance
wasn't always good.
So some of the challenges
that we've run into
are first of all Anycast is
optimized by the carriers
by the individual
service providers.
They can set their own policies
Twitter can't necessarily
control making sure
that a certain service
provider provides the best
experience for Twitter
users versus other users.
The service provider may
optimize for their own traffic
or for different types of
traffic versus Twitter traffic.
Another issue is with
capacity and with location,
getting close to the users.
If Twitter wants to add a
new location on our network,
we have to do a lot
of research and we
have to incur a lot of
cost in engineering.
So it's difficult
if the World Cup
is going to be in a
new location where
we don't have good
connectivity or a good POP--
or sorry, a local POP.
Or the Olympics are going
to be somewhere again, where
it's challenging for
Twitter users to connect.
It's difficult for us to quickly
add a new location, especially
if it's going to be somewhere
temporary where we just
need a burst of capacity.
Let's look a little
bit into some
of the problems with
Anycast IPs that we've seen.
So with our Anycast
IPs, our end users--
so here, let's assume
that this purple icon
is a user somewhere
in Europe that's
trying to connect
with the Twitter edge.
They have the Twitter
global Anycast IP,
and that edge can resolve to
one of n different regions.
One of n different edges
that exist in Europe.
It's up to this blob
called the internet
to figure out if this will
go to Edge A or Edge B
and the path it
takes to get there.
And this blob is
actually made up
of lots of different hops,
individual service providers,
transit providers, and various
agreements between them
on how traffic is rabid.
This can change throughout
the course of a day
and based on a variety
of settings that
are made by people frequently.
So the path from the
end user to Twitter
is not always going to
be the most optimal path.
Additionally, when Twitter
has to send the response back
to the end user, Twitter can
just choose the first hop back.
Then that one may take
a circuitous route back
to the end user.
Again, both of these
directions may not
be optimal at a
given point in time.
They could be based on time of
day, network feedback, round
robin algorithms, a
variety of things.
So this is pretty
good for availability,
but it's not great for latency.
Furthermore, it doesn't always
seem logical to our engineers,
or at least to me.
This chart shows where
requests from users
in South Korea, which
Twitter edge the request
ended up on in the
course of a day,
during the course of a day.
I personally would have expected
almost all of the requests
to show up at our edge location,
which is in eastern Asia.
We have multiple
locations in Asia,
I would have expected
that the South Korean user
requests would end up there.
Turned out only
about 60% of requests
ended up there, where
the other 40% of requests
ended up going to Europe
or going to the US.
We also noticed a
lot of deviation
in the overall
latency histograms,
large standard deviation.
Some of this is attributed to
the return path that Twitter
was taking, or just some
of these really long paths
that the user
requests were taking.
So improvements that
we've made to mitigate
some of these problems.
One of them has been
to expand our edge
by using the public cloud,
specifically the Google Cloud,
the Google load balancers.
So this is really increased
our global footprint.
So however many POPs we
had before, now we also
have the entire Google POP
network as well to ingress
user traffic.
With all of Google's
BGP optimizations
and peering agreements with
the various service providers,
and the return paths as well.
Also we've acknowledged that
we can't control making sure
that service providers
provide the optimal path
from a specific user to Twitter.
So what we've decided
to do is we've
setup a variety of
different VIPs, instead
of a single global Anycast
VIP, or a single set
of global Anycast VIPs.
And what we've
done is we measure
all of these different
VIPs, and then we
can optimize how an
individual user connects
to Twitter by applying the
best VIP for that user.
So looking back at this
diagram again, the end user,
we can give them our
global Anycast VIP.
They can connect
through the internet
through all of those hops and
end up at Edge A or Edge B,
and then we can
return it to them.
We can also provide
another in this case,
this VIP also took the
same path to Edge A,
but perhaps in this case
Twitter's BGP policy says
that the return path will always
go to a specific provider.
And we can measure how this
red and this black path
are performing over
the course of the day.
And we can prefer
one or the other
for our individual end users.
We can also set
up Anycast VIPs so
that our user is
making a request
and it forces them to land
on Edge B in this case,
or perhaps it doesn't work.
We can, again, measure it
and we can provide this
if it's a good option
for the end user.
Also, we can set up
lots and lots of VIPs
in the public Cloud that
are up to Google edges,
and then also provide
Google various ways
to route back to Twitter and
measure all these as well.
The system we've set
up that uses real time
measurements to choose from one
of hundreds of different VIPs
or routes back to Twitter
for individual end users,
we call it the
traffic control tower.
We steer individual users
to the best VIP for them
at that moment.
We use a variety of information.
We use net blocks, something
that's ISP identifiers,
and country codes to figure
out how to group measurements
the other.
We're able to route
around problems
that we see in the internet.
We're able to find optimized
routes from a user to Twitter
and back, and it's proven
very effective for us.
I'm going to hand it
back over to Cynthia
to talk a bit about
the Google network.
And then we'll look at
how Twitter specifically
uses the Google edge.
CYNTHIA THOMAS: Thanks, Tom.
So yeah, as Tom
mentioned, the internet
can definitely present itself
with inconsistent behavior
on the traffic path.
So clearly the
network matters and is
really important to the
end user experience.
With Google's
private backbone, we
can provide two types
of networking tiers.
So there's the standard
and premium tier.
So the Premium tier is
a unique combination
of providing speed
and reliability,
riding the Google
private backbone.
So the best analogy is pretty
much like a hot potato,
cold potato type behavior.
So the default
alternate behavior
would be like cold
or hot potato,
getting rid of the packets and
handing off to the internet
as soon as possible.
Whereas with the
Google premium tier,
we basically hang onto the
packet as long as possible,
deliver it, ride it over
our private backbone,
and then deliver it as close
to the destination or user
as possible.
So this enables basically
a better reliability,
performance, security, and
thus a better user experience.
So one networking contract
that Google provides
is the global load
balancer with Anycast it.
So this load balancer can
use to for Global reach,
for users to quickly
enter the Google backbone
and infrastructure in
traverse the private network
to its destination.
It provides worldwide capacity,
cross region failover,
and fast auto scaling, and the
ability to provide or handle
millions of queries per second.
So Twitter actually leverages
the Google Cloud load balancer
for edge reach
ability of services.
And basically this
Global load balancer
can be combined with both
Cloud CDM and Cloud Armor
for both caching and security
services while scaling.
So one powerful behavior
of the global load balancer
is the cross region failover,
the overflow in other regions.
So traffic is actually
a proxy to back ends
by a special algorithm called
the waterfall by region.
So if an entire region
reaches capacity,
the waterfall by region
algorithm is triggered
and traffic can
overflow to the closest
region with available capacity.
And traffic can also be
preemptively overflowing
to other regions in the event
of unhealthy back ends in this
I just want to talk a
little bit about NEGs,
so Network Endpoint Groups.
This is introduced
actually helps
a lot in containerized
environments
where without NEGs, there is
an IP tables rule that would
hop from one node to another.
So there is this
extra hop introduced.
Network Endpoint
Groups is basically
a collection of endpoints
defined as an IP port pair.
This allows things
like pods to be
directly reachable as back ends
to the global load balancer.
So what's interesting
about that is
you can use NEGs,
and other definitions
as well like
internet NEGs, which
would align to endpoints
that are actually outside
[INAUDIBLE].
So next time we'll
get into the details
of how Twitter uses Google
Cloud load balancing
and their deployments.
TODD SIEGEL: Thanks, Cynthia.
So there's two primary ways that
Twitter uses the Google edge.
So we use Google's POP network,
which is all over the world.
And we accept two
types of requests
through the load balancer.
One is Layer 4 only, and
the other is Layer 7.
So in this first
example, we're looking
at how Twitter uses
Google's TCP proxy.
So in this case, the Google
edge closest to the user
that will steer the user to
based on our traffic control
tower system, will terminate
TCP for the end user,
establish a
persistent connection
with a Twitter service, which
is running in GCP, the Google
Compute Region.
And then we will then proxy
that TV connection back
to one of many Twitter VIPs.
In this diagram
here you see there's
a blue, a purple,
and an orange VIP
that the Twitter service
and GCP will hand off to.
These represent different
paths back to Twitter.
So some of them ride
on the Google backbone
as far as possible.
Some of them hand off as
quickly as possible from Google
to the Twitter backbone,
or private interconnect.
So in this case,
using Layer 4 only,
provide some additional
security for Twitter in cases
where we want the
certificate to always remain
in the Twitter POP, or in
Twitter infrastructure.
Or also provides us with
some additional compatibility
if we have some
Twitter clients that
have special Twitter
only Level 7 behavior,
and various protocol,
idiosyncrasies, et cetera.
Additionally we use Google
pretty heavily as a Layer 7
proxy and we get multiple
benefits in this case.
So again, we set
up multiple VIPs
that all correspond to
the worldwide Google edge.
And the different
VIPs use the internet
NEG that Cynthia was
talking about before,
to route back to one
of n different Twitter
back in that piece.
And these IPs, again, they
correspond to different routes
back to Twitter either over the
Google backbone or the Twitter
backbone.
And again, we measure
those and send the user
to whichever one could
be performing the best,
or perhaps where we need
additional capacity.
And I'll talk
about that shortly.
In this case, as you
can see, the Google edge
does everything.
There's no service that
Twitter has to run inside GCP,
there's no deployments
we have to do,
there's no monitoring we have to
do besides overall Google Load
balancer monitoring.
So this has been
really great for us
and reduced the amount of
operations and deployments
that we've had to do to GCP.
Let's take a look at what this
has done for our end users.
With a combination
of the control tower
and expanding our
edge to regions
in two locations in
the public Cloud,
we've been able to pretty
dramatically improve
the performance for
many of our users.
This graph here shows
the improvements
at various percentiles
p25, p75, p99 for users
in different countries.
And this represents the user
measured at home timeline
request latency end to end.
So it includes all the back
end latency, the connection
establishment latency, transit
latency, et cetera, et cetera.
And as you can see in
all of these countries,
we've pretty
dramatically improved
some of the [INAUDIBLE]
latency, and even
some of the earlier
percentile latency as well.
We've seen this correspond to
greater satisfaction and usage
of Twitter in these
regions as well,
as failures have gone down.
And requests success
rate has gone up
and leniency has gone down.
One additional benefit from
using the public cloud edge
is from using Google
load balancer has
been additional capacity
that we've got it to use
with no deployment on our end.
This chart comes from a
recent event in South America.
There's a reality TV show
called Big Brother Brazil that
recently set the Guinness
Book of World Records
most online votes.
It took this away from
American idol, I believe.
And this purple line
here shows the number
of requests that happened
at the peak of voting
during this show, the number
of requests to Twitter.
And the red line
on the bottom shows
how much Twitter
on-prem capacity
that we have in South America.
And this peak was actually
three times the amount
of on-prem capacity
that we have.
So if we weren't able to
burst into the public cloud
and spill over into
our other regions,
Twitter likely would
have been just hard
down for the entire
continent of South America.
And by using the control
tower to steer users
to public cloud
endpoints and spillover
events and other things
that are performing well,
we not only kept
Twitter successfully up.
But we were able
to keep Twitter up
with really fantastic
performance for our end users
at this time.
Let me hand it off to Cynthia
to talk a bit about the Traffic
Director and hybrid network.
CYNTHIA THOMAS: So, yeah.
Let's talk a little
bit Traffic Director.
For those who don't
know, Traffic Director
is a managed control plane
enabling global services
with various types of
back ends and GCPs.
So that could include
GCE instances or GKE,
and programmatically
configures envoy proxies.
So it actually leverages
the Google Cloud load
balancer and this
is a powerful way
to serve applications globally,
and we have a global network.
Traffic Director additionally
allows for hybrid connectivity,
as it has the capability
to route traffic
to non GCP back ends.
So it's an additional way
Twitter can direct traffic
to its data centers.
All right, thanks for
watching our talk.
We made it to the end.
We hope you learned a little
bit about how Twitter scales
with Google edge networking.
Wanted to also-- if you wanted
more information about Traffic
Director, we have
follow up talks
that will dive deeper into the
Traffic Director abilities,
amongst many of the
other networking talks.
I want to also have a
special thanks to Todd
and the Twitter
team for walking us
through how Twitter
edge deployment is
using Google Cloud.
TODD SIEGEL: Great.
Thanks so much, Cynthia.
And a big thank you to
Cynthia and to the Google
team on this great partnership.
We have more resources about
the traffic control tower
and how Twitter uses the Google
edge in the public cloud up
on the Twitter engineering blog.
So check that out and
enjoy the other talks.
And thank you very much.
This was fun.
Bye.